la policía israelí mató sobre la una de
la mañana a un joven palestino en una de
las puertas de acceso a la Explanada de
las mezquitas donde se ubica alaxa y qué
horas Antes había reunido a unos 250.000
musulmanes en el segundo viernes de
ramadán sobre la muerte de este beduino
de 26 años residente en jura con
ciudadanía israelí hay versiones
encontradas las fuerzas israelíes
afirman que el joven intentó quitarle el
arma a uno de los policías durante un
control y que por eso otros oficiales le
dispararon sin embargo esto no concuerda
con el relato de Testigos palestinos que
sostienen que lo mataron en sus palabras
sin necesidad alguna al intervenir para
ayudar a una mujer que estaba siendo
detenida y acosada por la policía cuando
intentaba Acceder al lugar de rezo
Aunque es una zona repleta de cámaras y
los agentes suelen portar otras en su
uniforme las autoridades israelíes no
han difundido por ahora ninguna imagen
del momento de ese disparo horas después
del hecho algunos fieles indicaron que
las fuerzas israelíes endurecieron los
controles de acceso a la Explanada
Durante los rezos de la madrugada se
trata Eso sí del primer incidente mortal
en Jerusalén desde que el 22 de marzo
inició el mes sagrado musulmán periodo
que va a coincidir con la Pascua judía y
la semana santa cristiana y que en años
anteriores ha estado atravesado por
grandes escaladas de violencia